first few days of the campaign have seen
Teresa make dogged by questions about
taxes and pensions one man who I'm sure
will provide clear and straightforward
answers is the work and Pensions
Secretary Damian Green who joins us now
from central London and I'm looking
forward to this clear and
straightforward answers mr. green
firstly on reports that the
Conservatives are planning to cap gas
and electricity bills I mean I'm getting
a sense of deja vu here it sounds an
awful lot like the kind of thing ed
Miliband was saying at the last election
we do think the energy market isn't
working properly and we do want to
change the way it operates you'll be
seeing all the details in our manifesto
the difference with the Ed Miliband plan
is that Ed Miliband
just said there would be a freeze
imposed by the government and
immediately after that as you remember
oil prices and therefore gas prices fell
around the world so people wouldn't have
had the advantage of the market changes
what we're going to propose is something
different which is much more sensitive
to movements in the market off gem would
be able to cap but in relation to what
the market price is so that what we will
get rid of is big energy companies
exploiting their customers that I think
is what many people think rightly is
unfair about the energy market and
that's that's what we will do the same
time that it sounds like it's quite a
small difference between a cap and a
freeze if you take into consideration at
your colleague Michael Fallon described
Ed Miliband's policy as extremely
dangerous at the time well they would
have been as I say that and dangerous
and and also as it happens the Ed
Miliband proposal would have cost people
money because the market price then
unexpectedly fell labour would have
imposed a freeze that would have been a
freeze at a higher level then the market
was giving we're proposing as I say a
more flexible system which will be able
to react to the market but which will
mean that any energy company that starts
trying to exploit its customers won't be
able to do do so using off gem the the
regulator to make sure that energy
prices
mein fair okay well it's pretty clear
that you're planning to do something on
energy bills so I wonder if you can be
quite as forthcoming about whether or
not you're going to keep the triple lock
on pensions that guarantees that they'll
go up every year are you gonna keep that
yes or no once we'll be fine the auto
afraid is you'll have to wait for the
manifesto for the details of all our
policies you wouldn't expect me and and
your viewers wouldn't expect me to
partially leak our manifesto now and I'm
afraid I'm not going to do so but but
I'm quite happy for people to inspect
our record on pensions and how we've
protected pensioners thirty forty years
ago forty percent of pensioners in this
country lived in poverty that number is
now down to fourteen percent it's a huge
achievement and of course there's always
more to do but making sure we strike the
right balance for all generations is
clearly very important but the reduction
in pension poverty is something of which
I'm very proud you say that we wouldn't
expect you to spell out your manifesto
of course that's true but at the same
time the Conservatives have acted
quickly to dampen down speculation in
other areas such as Theresa now saying
that the international aid pledge will
stay for example shall we conclude then
that the triple lock on pensions is on
the table
no you should conclude I'm sorry to have
to ask you to be patient Sophie but you
will have to be patient until you have
the manifesto what I can assure you is
that the manifesto will reflect Tereza
mayor's plan for Britain so in the four
big areas where we want to be a global
country we want a stronger economy we
want a fairer society and we want to
keep the united kingdom united that will
run through all the policies in the
manifesto but but you will have to wait
for the detailed policies I'm afraid
okay I'm going to resist from asking the
same question I hope three times and
hoping for an answer how about taxes
will you keep the promise you made last
time that national insurance income tax
and also v80 will not go up under a
Conservative government or a day on the
table this time what well as I say I'll
keep saying I'm afraid of you if you ask
me to give detailed answers about the
manifesto I won't do so but again look
at our record the Conservative Party
believes in low taxes is always a lower
tax party than the alternative
government that the Labour government
and you've seen that that we've taken
four million people out of income tax
altogether over the past few years we've
cut income tax for 31 million people so
you can be absolutely guaranteed that
taxes will always be lower under a
Conservative government than they would
be under a Jeremy Corbyn government so
let me get this straight then you're
talking about a cap on energy bills
you're protecting foreign aid you're not
ruling out tax rises and you're also not
ruling out getting rid of the triple
lock on pensions have you got mixed up
here and got Labour's manifesto in your
hand rather than the Conservatives no I
I'm not telling you all to the
conservative manifesto because I'm
afraid we want to release it at the at
the right time but but you as I say you
can be guaranteed you don't need to look
into a crystal ball or try and you know
find out what might be in the manifesto
you can look at our record it's a record
of even as a time of austerity even when
the public finances
were under extreme pressure we've
managed to find ways to cut taxes for
hard-working people particularly at the
lower end of the income spectrum we
recognize that there are things like
unfairness in society one of which is in
the energy market and and we will deal
with that that's that's a very
conservative message we are on the side
of hard-working families and we are
particularly keen that people who do the
right thing shouldn't feel that that
life is unfair now today we're seeing
another part of the conservative
campaign which is all about trying to
paint Jeremy Corbyn as a risk to
national security your Party Chairman
for example saying that we wouldn't be
safe under Jeremy Corbyn he of course
was really asked lots of questions about
his views on security early this morning
as well is this scare mongering to try
and paint the Labour leader as a risk to
national security is this really where
the conservative campaign is going well
you just have to listen to what Jeremy
Corbyn said what he said this morning
was that he would dismantle Britain's
nuclear defenses and he would fail to
deal effectively with terrorism this man
could be Prime Minister in seven weeks
time I can't think of a better reason
for sticking with the strong leadership
of Teresa May than the fact that Jeremy
Corbyn would dismantle this country's
defenses so you're talking about the
strong leadership of Teresa made the
other thing that's winning in areas as
this campaign goes on is stability
the Conservatives it's a part of
stability but just look at your record
over the last few years we've had an EU
referendum the power sharing in Northern
Ireland is on the brink of collapse the
Union has never looked more fragile
we've got the prospect of another
Scottish referendum and we've got a
general election I mean that doesn't
sound like stability does it
well what this election will do is give
the British people the chance to vote
for stability and strong leadership we
now have this this pause this period
inside the negotiations with the rest of
the EU where we can have a general
election where I hope the British people
will give Teresa may a strong mandate so
that Britain can get the best possible
results from these negotiations and
indeed many other problems you mentioned
of course those are the sort of problems
that all governments face and that you
need strong and stable leadership to
deal with and and you have a contrast at
this election that choice with other
people at this election is either the
the strong and stable leadership that
Teresa may provides or Jeremy Corbyn
with a ragbag of other parties that
don't agree with him supporting him
making a coalition of people thank you
very much